nobody really cares about Martin Luther
King everybody pretends to care about
Martin Luther King but nobody actually
cares about Martin Luther King and
certainly not the people who most
exploit his name like Joe Biden showing
up at I believe an event for the
National Action Network and he goes
there and he pretends he pretends that
he fought with the Civil Rights
activists and he makes up all these
stories and he was out there marching on
Washington with corn pop or whatever and
he saw Martin Luther King leaned so much
to me and his daughter-in-law means so
much to me what's your name anyway
I love black people give me money
support me if you're not if you don't
vote for me you ain't black happy Martin
Luther King day if you don't vote for me
I'm depriving you of your racial
identity it's just so pathetic it's just
pure pandering and I have to tell you I
am delighted in on those occasions when
he's caught doing it